[Musique]
mai 1940 le monde regarde en désespoir
les envahisseurs nazis faire une guerre
éclair contre la france
fr une marche triomphale à travers les
rues de paris
il
[Musique]
mais derrière les larves d'un peuple
vaincu le grondement de la révolte se
fait entendre les français mécontents
suivent l'appel du général de gaulle et
luttent pour la liberté au moyen d'une
organisation clandestine dédiés à des
sabotages et autre acte de défi contre
l'ennemi la résistance
[Musique]
cette résistance grandit peu à peu des
hommes et des femmes s'y sont joints
sans distinction de convictions
politiques morales ou religieuses
je suis devenu le fondateur du comité
parisien de libération ainsi que de
l'organisation qui gérait la résistance
et la révolte nationale
hitler visite et lui même la france
pendant l'occupation il s'énervait les
grands monuments et il se délecter de sa
conquête
[Musique]
même la tour eiffel âgé de 51 ans et de
300 mètres de haut et est occupée par
les allemands qui l'utilisaient pour
envoyer des messages côté à leur armée
[Musique]
de manière ironique la silhouette de la
tour se détachant sur l'horizon de paris
est devenue symbolique de l'espoir
résistante d'une france libre
c'était un symbole de liberté un symbole
de la france sous l'occupation idée de
savoir qu'un jour on serait libre de
monter sur la tour eiffel prédominait
parmi les français quand les armées
alliées ont enfin libéré paris quelques
français libres sont montés en haut de
la tour eiffel pour célébrer en
déployant le drapeau tricolore français
en bas les citoyens craché juré contre
les allemands qui s'enfuyaient mais les
berthet égalité fraternité exiger leur
monte de gloire du haut de la tour
eiffel pour la plupart des gens la tour
eiffel est un symbole de la france c'est
une lumière et un espoir une poésie et
une magie
sa géométrie complexe cachent les rêves
des amoureux les français peuvent jouir
dans l'honneur d'avoir créé et érigé ce
monument internationale en son âme se
trouvent les coeurs des gens libres du
monde entier voici l'histoire de la tour
eiffel
[Musique]
la hauteur remarquable de la tour eiffel
suggère un sentiment de triomphe
elle oriente les regards vers le ciel et
en même temps elle apporte une
perspective calmante sur le monde d'en
bas
[Musique]
tout au long de l'histoire l'humanité a
défilé possibilité de l'architecturé du
génie civil pour parvenir à des édifices
d'une hauteur considérable soit dans le
but d'espionner l'ennemi soit pour
s'efforcer de se rapprocher de dieu
certains cherchent à trouver une
utilisation pratique des tours elle
pourrait être utilisée pourrait disposer
des antennes de transmission
elle pourrait également être un endroit
convenable pour un restaurant mais le
véritable charme des tours provient
d'une notion plus profondes que celles
mentionnées précédemment les tours
représente la célébration de la volonté
elle parle à nos ambitions elle exprime
un témoignage de la joie de vivre
la tour eiffel et la tour la plus
célébrée de par le monde sa hauteur
grandiose son contour délicat sa
solidité éthérée
tout cela reflète les meilleurs traits
du caractère français
[Musique]
la tour a été construite en 1889 pour
célébrer le centenaire de la révolution
française
[Musique]
le 14 juillet 1789 le peuple français
dans un flot de patients révolutionnaire
s'est soulevée contre l'aristocratie
française et a pris d'assaut la bastille
prison infâme où l'on enfermé les
pauvres et ceux qui n'étaient pas loin
you au régime politique
la révolte se répondu à travers la
france et les patriotes se sont ralliés
à l'appel de la liberté de la
marseillaise
[Musique]
le bouleversement nationaliste s'est
fait entendre à travers l'europe et à
jouer le rôle de support des mouvements
démocratiques modernes
les français avaient le droit d'être
fiers des contributions positives que la
révolution avait amené mais un siècle
plus tard la défaite de la france au
profit de l'allemagne a blessé la fierté
française l'idée d'organiser une
exposition spectaculaire semblait offrir
un moyen excellent d'évoquer les
souvenirs d'un passé glorieux et
d'oublier les échecs d'aujourd'hui on
était encore triste à cause de la guerre
contre l'allemagne de 1870 et on avait
perdu deux provinces l'alsace et la
lorraine
tels étaient des sentiments des français
de l'époque les gens étaient contents de
l'exposition pour montrer leur grandeur
et que le pays peut céder encore
d'importantes ressources
on a décidé qu'il fallait une sorte de
jalons pour la célébration un ouvrage
d'art qui dominerait la masse
la bravade de l'âge industriel a suggéré
l'idée d'un ouvrage de génie civil une
tour
la tour eiffel a joué un rôle important
du point de vue une boisson
technologique personnes avaient pu
construire auparavant une tour de 300
mètres de haut
de nombreux essais avaient été faits en
amérique on avait élaboré plusieurs
projets sans jamais les mener à bien
on a donc organisé un concours de
projets des architectes venant de toutes
les régions de france ont soumis leurs
plans détaillés le premier projet a été
proposé par un homme du nom de maurice
coquelin il était un des premiers à se
joindre à l'équipe de gustave eiffel
gustave eiffel était un architecte et
ingénieur d' excellente renommée en
france
il était connu pour son succès dans le
domaine de la construction des ponts il
a examiné le concept révolutionnaire de
la construction à l'aide de charpente
métallique son génie à attirer dans son
atelier les architectes les plus d'eau
et pouvoir s'associer à monsieur eiffel
dans le développement d'un projet en
assurer les fonds et la réalisation
maurice koechlin et emile nougier deux
jeunes ingénieurs de l'équipe dfl ont
élaboré le premier plan d'une tour de
300 mètres à l'occasion de l'exposition
de paris de 1889
ils ont fait les ébauches la structure
est l'architecte stephen sauvestre et y
ajouter les ornements des éléments
fleurot en forme d'arc et des nuances
culturales
[Musique]
le projet a été inspiré par l'idée
romantique répandue dans l' architecture
française de 1887
selon laquelle on pourrait atteindre le
ciel si l'on franchisse et une hauteur
de 300 m qui était juste là hors de
portée après avoir examiné le projet
monsieur effet la partager les idées des
deux ingénieurs
au début il a simplement ajouter son nom
au projet pour lui donner de meilleures
chances de gagner le concours
cependant il s'y est vite intéressé et y
apporter ses propres ornements le nom
d'eiffel associé à un projet signifier
qu'il remporterait la victoire les
contacts dfl auprès des bureaucrates
parisien lui permettait de faire
approuver un projet de plus il posséder
les compétences techniques nécessaires
pour le transformer en une réalité de
trois dimensions la tour devrait
représenter le rôle de la france à
l'époque industrielle
beaucoup de monde a profité du succès de
la tour eiffel qui était à la fois un
symbole et un défi des règles du génie
civil
toutefois fl était décidé à montrer à
travers son projet un esprit innovateur
[Musique]
c'est de l'air et de la lumière c'est
une forme et un mouvement aussi forte
que la détermination humaine aussi été
ré que ses pensées
la tour eiffel est un monument hors du
commun
sa construction reflète à la fois l'idée
des éléments préfabriqués de l'époque
industrielle et des théories avancées de
la construction du début du 20e siècle
le 28 février 1887 un groupe de
dignitaires s'est rassemblée pour
assister au commencement des travaux
gustave eiffel avait alors 54 ans et la
tour devait être sa plus grande réussite
pendant que la cérémonie se poursuivait
50 ingénieurs étaient en train de
préparer 5300 plan détaillé pour les 132
ouvriers sur le site on a exécuté les
fondations de la tour en quatre mois
deux piliers ont été établis sur des
massifs de béton de deux mètres de
profondeur qui reposait à 7 m environ
sous le niveau du sol est les deux
piliers ont été installés si proche de
la scène qu'on devait employer des
caissons étanches métallique afin de
faire durcir le béton
les quatre piliers étaient entourés par
un carré dans les côtés étaient 230 m
cela a permis de répartir également les
7000 tonnes de fer employé dans la
construction sur les fondations on a
élevé des massifs en béton dans lesquels
des normes boulons ont été enfoncés dans
chacune des arêtes les piliers
construits comme des poutres creuse de
charpente devait se dresser formant un
angle de 60 degrés et les effets de
support et de barres plate il fallait
quatre de ses éléments pour assembler
une poutre entière
la poutre possède la même dynamique
structurale qu'une série de cube
encastré
[Musique]
et c'est ici le génie du projet dfl la
charpente est aussi solide que la pierre
mais plus légère elle a été montée
facilement avec des matériaux moins cher
[Musique]
dix-huit mille pièces métalliques et
25000 river ont été employés dans la
construction de la tour
tous les éléments étaient soit des bars
plate soit des supports ou des plaques
[Musique]
la première étape de la construction a
été très délicate
il fallait monter des pini simultanément
afin qu'ils se rencontrent au niveau
horizontal du premier étage de la tour
l'angle des piliers exiger des
échafaudages pour chacun d'eux ainsi
qu'un échafaudage centrale pour soutenir
la poutre qui maintient l'ensemble de la
construction des criques de 800 tonnes
manipulées à l'aide de pompes
hydrauliques ont été installés au
dessous de chaque pilier afin de les
monter ou de les baisser d'une manière
indépendante pour obtenir une position
précise cette étape achevée
gustave eiffel savait que rien ne
pouvait arrêter la réalisation du projet
malgré ce qui essayait d'empêcher sa
réussite
fl a rencontré l'opposition des gens des
alentours de la tour qui craignaient que
la construction ne s'effondre sur leur
maison
personne ne voulait couvrir les dégâts
c'est donc eiffel qui l'a fait
de plus il y avait ceux qui craignaient
que la tourner détruisent l'horizon de
paris au début des travaux certains
voulaient suspendre la construction de
la tour un groupe d'écrivains et
d'architectes les ont dénoncés en
montrant le côté scandale de leurs
protestations
la communauté artistique de paris
regarder la tour comme un affront fait à
la beauté de la ville par l'industrie
une douzaine d'écrivains et de peintres
ont même attaqué la construction de la
tour dans une déclaration publique
je pense que paris est menacée un
artiste l'a comparé à un pied de lampe
qui sort du coeur de paris
la réponse des faits elle n'a pas été
moins passionné il s'est exclamé
la tour sera la construction la plus
haute qu'on ait faite
[Musique]
le 1er août 1888 la tour de paris avec
ses 300 mètres de haut
représenter une éruption de métal
s'élançant vers le ciel elle représente
l esprit de la france
le grand public semblait enfin se mettre
à l'aimer
[Musique]
en effet les parisiens et le grand
public admirait la tour eiffel bien
qu'au début la tournée d'été qu'une
forme squelettiques
elle représentait maintenant une oeuvre
majestueuse et gracieuse à la fois la
pente harmonieuse des arêtes les
ornements en contraste avec les boulons
c'était un ouvrage d'art qui s'adressait
à un monde agité qui se préparer à des
changements dramatiques
les travaux progressent à vitesse
étonnante sous la direction de gustave
eiffel et les menées avec la précision
d'un dirigeant militaire
on l'aurait cru engagé dans une bataille
héroïque de chercheurs en effet les
éléments de la tour ont été préparés à
l' usine d'eiffel sur le site
il n'y avait que 300 ouvriers environ
tout ce coupé au montage
le site ressembler à un jeu de
construction avec des pièces jeter comme
ça et là
[Musique]
des équipes de quatre hommes poser les
rives et pour que les travaux se
maintiennent à une vitesse frénétique
des cons assembler un chargement
d'éléments des grues de 12 tonnes en
livrer davantage
tout cela en utilisant l'espace des
cages d'ascenseur qui plus tard se
réinstaller le deuxième étage a été
achevé un an après le début des travaux
la tour entière a été achevée en moins
d'un an après cela le 31 mars 1889
l'assemblage de cette construction qui
restera la plus haute du monde pendant
les quarante ans qui suivent a pris
seulement deux ans deux mois et 5 jours
il n'y a pas eu d'accident lors des
travaux dangereux qui défie les règles
établies
fl a été le premier à monter les 1710
marches de la tour jusqu'au sommet où il
a déployé le drapeau français
au bas de la tour se trouvait paris il
semblait que l'homme de la ville passer
à travers les pili solide de la tour et
se disperser dans le ciel pour célébrer
l'événement
la tour avec ses 300 mètres de haut
était le centre d'attention lors de
l'ouverture de l'exposition universelle
de paris en 1889
on l'appelait la plus grande structure
du monde pour éblouir le public avant
d'être baptisé sous le nom de la tour
eiffel
[Musique]
au début on appelait la tour la tour de
320 mètres et même le pylône de 320
mètres je ne sais pas exactement quand
elle est devenue la tour de monsieur
eiffel et plus tard la tour eiffel à mon
avis il n'a pas pensé qu'elle
deviendrait plus qu'une haute structure
à grande envergure
la tour eiffel était la fois quelconque
et majestueuse à l'époque la tour était
la construction la plus haute du monde
et gustave eiffel lâche iris et grâce
aux revenus immense qu'elle assurerait
[Musique]
monsieur eiffel a en effet financé la
construction de la tour
il a avancé la plupart des fonds
nécessaires pour les travaux mais a
conclu un accord financier il assuré 80%
défend à condition de recevoir le droit
d'exploiter la tour pendant une période
de 20 ans s'il n'avait pas été certain
du succès de la tour il n'aurait jamais
pris ce risque
gustave eiffel avait son propre
appartement dans la tour où il faisait
des expérimentations scientifiques et
accueilli des personnalités importantes
deux millions de personnes ont visité la
tour eiffel la première année la vente
des billets lui assurer un revenu de 2
millions de dollars eiffel a fait
fortune grâce aux visiteurs de la tour
il est ainsi devenu très riche
fl n'était pas un artiste c'était un
entrepreneur
l'opinion est partagée à l'égard de la
personnalité de gustave eiffel à cause
de la nature conflictuelle de son
caractère
sans formation artistique fl grâce à sa
construction métallique a établi une
sorte d'esthétisme qu'on admire
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il aurait pu devenir un héros national
après la construction de la tour en 1889
cependant l'année suivante il a été
accusé d'avoir profité des projets de la
france pour construire le canal de
panama le canal était le rêve de
l'ingénieur français ferdinand de
lesseps qui voyait l'occasion de répéter
la réussite de son projet à suez de
lesseps a demandé à eiffel d'aménager
une voie navigable à travers la jungle
eiffel a proposé un système innovateur
des cluses de lesseps à rejeter le plan
et les conséquences ont été désastreuses
on ne peut pas creuser des canaux
travers des marécages et la jungle le
projet s'est avéré si cher et si
désavantageux que le gouvernement
français s'est retrouvé au bord de la
faillite
l'afer a eu des retombées politiques
sévères on a diffamé ceux qui avaient un
lien quelconque avec le projet fl a été
condamné à 24 mois de prison
malgré sa réhabilitation plus tard il a
quitté le domaine de la construction
[Musique]
tous les ingénieurs considère fl comme
un dieu
c'était un homme dévoué à la science la
tour a donc été sa dernière construction
à l'âge de 73 ans eiffel s'est consacré
à d'autres études scientifiques surtout
dans le domaine de l'aérodynamique
d'autres visionnaire français tels
l'écrivain jules verne ont appliqué les
concepts rudimentaire du 19e siècle
comme le montre ce film proposons un
voyage sur la lune
fl s'est rendu compte que le progrès de
l'aviation dépend des des recherches sur
les éléments de la nature
mais à la différence des chercheurs qui
par exemple s'était lancé dans l'idée de
création mécanique étrange où sa tâche
et des ailes autour des bras pour sauter
de la tour eiffel a créé un atelier de
recherche qui fonctionnent encore
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
monsieur eiffel a fait les premières
expérimentations dans le domaine de la
résistance de l'air auxquels il s'est
confronté toute sa vie pour lui
le vent était l'ennemi principal alors
de 1906 à 1909 il a étudié les questions
de la résistance aérodynamique
voilà pourquoi il a créé la première
soufflerie c'est là où vous êtes ainsi
que les recherches de l'aérodynamique
françaises ont commencé
il faut noter que cette soufflerie
ce ventilateur et ce moteur sont les
originaux on les a gardé intacte tels
qu'ils étaient autrefois
quant aux appareils de mesure on les a
adaptés pour faire des travaux moderne
monsieur eiffel était un ingénieur hors
du commun
en regardant tout ce qu'il a pu faire on
a pu remarquer qu'aujourd'hui on a
recréé des choses qu'il avait déjà fait
lui-même en 1917
la tour eiffel avec ses 300 mètres de
haut ne devait vivre que 20 ans
[Musique]
mais gustave eiffel s'est accoutumé à y
accueillir des gens pour garder sa
popularité notamment auprès des
parisiens
[Musique]
voilà pourquoi il a mené une campagne
pour sauver la tour plus de 5000 des
expérimentations ont été faites dans son
atelier mais c'est la radio qui a sauvé
la tour
[Musique]
la construction métallique grandiose et
est devenue une antenne et maîtrise
parfaite de son sommet on pouvait
transmettre jusqu'en amérique du nord
par conséquent au lieu d'être démonté à
la tour a obtenu un sursis grâce à la
radio qui particulièrement a permis aux
français de surveiller les aléas de la
guerre avec l'allemagne
[Musique]
en 1914 la première guerre mondiale a
balayé l'europe
le conflit était si proche de paris que
les soldes aller au front en taxi
mais à l'aide de la tour les généraux
français pouvaient surveiller le
mouvement de l'ennemi et donner l'alerté
contre les ai plein
[Musique]
gustave eiffel et morts en 1923 cinq ans
après les dernières répercussions de la
guerre grâce à sa créativité
la france était au premier rang des
technologies novatrices
[Musique]
son interprétation architectural et
scientifique incarné dans sa tour
représente une sorte d'introduction au
principe du 20e siècle
désormais la construction se rallier à
l'idée d'assembler de petits éléments
[Musique]
on
c'est un concept qui appartient aux
temps modernes
[Musique]
on
après la dévastation de la guerre paris
est soucieuse de retrouver un certain
optimisme est de connaître de meilleurs
jours
cependant il se dégageait un courant
suttil de désespoir dans une ambiance
festive comme si le bon temps dissimuler
les problèmes que la guerre avait laissé
[Musique]
dans les années 20 une génération perdue
et désillusionné a atteint paris
[Musique]
certains parisien de l'après-guerre
étaient des artistes et intellectuels
américains cherchant un sens logique
dans un monde qui semblait chaotique f
scott fitzgerald et son épouse zelda
charlie chaplin des vedettes de cinéma
des peintres des artistes des créateurs
tous ont été attirés par une révolution
de la pensée qu'on appelait
l'existentialisme ce que nous sommes
est ce la somme de notre existence le
temps et la poésie ne sont ils que des
fantaisies absurde le thème sombre de
l'aliénation est apparu dans l'art de
façon ironique à la tour proposait un
lien visuel et symbolique vers des temps
plus tourné vers la légèreté et le calme
de plus gustave eiffel avait employé un
métal lourd et solide pour créer une
beauté sans lourdeur c'était une idée
rassurante
la tour eiffel n'est pas seulement fait
de faire mais aussi dair circulant dans
un treillis de métal
certains visiteurs avaient l'impression
de n'être nulle part ce sentiment
suggère que la structure n'est pas le
matériel essentiel de la tour mais que
l'on doit aussi considérer l'importance
du vide intérieur la construction
ambitieuse semblé former un lien
poétique entre le 19ème et le 20ème
siècle ce lien sera interrompue d'une
manière brutale par le fascisme le
racisme et les meurtres qui sont apparus
des cendres de la défaite allemande au
cours de la première guerre mondiale
[Musique]
en mai 1940 les nazis ont pris d'assaut
paris et la tour eiffel
cependant les troupes allemandes ont eu
du mal à utiliser le monument puisque
les français avaient détruit les
ascenseurs le sabotage a empêché hitler
de jouir de sa conquête
[Musique]
il y à une photo très connu dit claire
au trocadéro regardant la tour sans
pouvoir monter au sommet il n'y avait
pas d'ascenseur il ne pouvait pas et
monte furieux contre les occupants nazis
les parisiens ont mené une contre
attaque désespérée
les français libres comploté contre les
occupants dans les catacombes romaines
sous les rues de la ville
[Musique]
les tunnels qui cachait le reste des
français oubliés et vaincu était
maintenant l'abri de la résistance vous
savez qu'il y a des passages souterrains
sous la capitale française
par conséquent les catacombes ont joué
un rôle important pour la résistance
elle permettait de se déplacer sans être
vu pour mener la lutte contre
l'occupation de paris
donc on a fait dérailler des trains qui
se dirigeait vers le front atlantique
j'ai pris part aux sabotages des rails
autour de paris il n'y avait que des
trains transportant des soldats sur ses
rails là un jour on a appris qu'un train
passait près de là ville
ce train contourner paris on a fait les
préparatifs on l'a fait dérailler mais
c'était affreux
le train transportait de la choucroute
il y avait de la choucroute partout sur
des kilomètres hitler mépriser les
français libres et voulait détruire
leurs monuments
à la fin de la guerre il a ordonné le
bombardement de la tour eiffel cependant
le général von choltitz amoureux de
paris a épargné la tour contrairement
aux ordres reçus
[Musique]
peuples de l'europe de l'ouest des
troupes alliées expéditionnaire ont
atterri sur la côte française ce matin
l'heure de votre libération s'approche
[Musique]
enfin les chars américains ont chassé
les nazis de la tour eiffel
[Musique]
mais quand paris a été libérée le
gouvernement français était en pleine
confusion les anciens dirigeants
n'étaient pas plus là tandis que la
génération suivante n'était pas encore
prête à redonner au pays sa gloire
l'autre fois de 1945 à 1960 la france a
eu 20 gouvernement provisoire
la confusion politique a persisté
jusqu'au moment où on a persuadé le
général de gaulle à aider le pays à
sortir des calamités de l'après guerre
un homme d'une telle force et d'un
caractère exceptionnel représentait la
seule possibilité de sauver la france
de gaulle assure ali le pays a battu et
lui redonner le moral
cependant c'était la tour eiffel sete
cage gigantesque qui a toujours
sauvegarder son esprit mais la tour
eiffel afin de survivre exiger de
nouvelles obligations pour sa bonne
continuation de même que la france avait
besoin d'une nouvelle optique pour la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle
[Musique]
on a conçu la tour eiffel en tant que
jalons de l'exposition universelle de
1889 maintenant un siècle plus tard la
fête continue avec plus de 1000
visiteurs montant la tour toutes les
heures
quatre ascenseurs installés dans les
quatre piliers orienté à 60°
transportent les touristes jusqu'au
sommet
le choeur des machineries se trouve dans
les catacombes
on retrouve des objets que l'on aurait
pu imaginer que dans les fantaisies de
jules verne
[Musique]
au début il y avait une cabine poussé
par un fiston qui fonctionnait grâce à
de l'eau sous pression qui assurait la
force hydraulique nécessaire au
mouvement
cette technologie qui a un siècle en
représente une mosaïque animé qui fait
penser à un jeu mécanique gigantesque
ce segment mis en rubans de coton et
celui qu'on pressent son gré c'est avec
du gras de moutons et de la grèce de
rognons vous voyez très large très belle
deux fois par semaine ici ça sent le
méchoui de l'agneau rôti de l'afrique du
nord c'est ça
quatre sets
la vieille technologie marche bien ce
que j'ai là c'est du cuir et oui c'est
du cuir le même matériel cependant il
est comprimé et il a une forme
différente
c'est un cuir imprégnés d'huile
il est obtenu à partir des sabots des
boeufs en 1980 on a décidé de moderniser
le système à l'aide d'équipements de
pointe
[Musique]
c'est une fusion entre le moteur ferrari
est celui d'un mac traque au troisième
étage une autre range et d'ascenseurs
transporte les visiteurs jusqu'au sommet
ici les travaux de maintenance ne cesse
jamais chaque jour une équipe de 28
ouvriers montent sur la plateforme et
trois du sommet pour reprendre la
décoration de la tour une opération qui
prend 18 mois
c'est le même procédé qu'on a utilisées
lors de la première décoration de la
tour on utilise plus de 50 tonnes de
peinture tous les sept ans pour la
décoration
c'est venu comme ça j'avais 18 ans c'est
venu comme ça j'avais 18 ans et je suis
devenu peintre
je me sens privilégiée est heureux de
pouvoir travailler sur un monument
important comme la tour eiffel
oui c'est important de travailler à la
tour eiffel
je suis très content cependant la
peinture industrielle est un métier
spécialisé qui exige à la fois une force
physique et un bon moral là il faut
reconnaître que c'est dangereux il faut
être fort
de plus cela exige un sens de l'
équilibre plus je suis au et mieux je me
sens les peintres ne sont pas les seuls
sur la tour eiffel
il y a aussi les électriciens je préfère
travailler là haut que dans un bureau
je pense que mes amis sont du même avis
ici on est en plein air ou même ce qu'on
fait c'est une sorte de privilège de
travailler sur un monument tel que la
tour eiffel comme elle n'est pas abriter
la structure est parfois endommagées par
les éléments naturels les tuyaux
pourrait geler et se percer si le
système de chauffage ne les protège et
pas il y a des gaines de calfeutrage
avec des thermostats autour des tuyaux
les rubans se met en marche dès que la
température descend près de zéro les
tuyaux sont ainsi réchauffer
la tâche principale les électriciens et
de maintenir la beauté des lumières et
le surveille échange les 360 ampoules de
la tour cependant monté jusqu'au 12
dérange parfois les vrais habitants de
la tour
les oiseaux ils sont attirés par la
lumière dès qu'il s'approche il s'égare
un peu en essayant de sortir il reste
enfermé ont la plupart d'entre eux
réussissent à s'évader
on aperçoit aussi des faucons creyssel
qui font leur nid dans les poutres en
acier
ça fait plaisir on est plutôt accoutumés
à voir des pigeons à paris en début de
soirée les derniers rayons de soleil de
couleur or et rose temps ou sur les
toits de paris sur les musées sur les
monuments et sur les couples et se
retrouve
la tour eiffel répond comme si sa robe
refléter le feu de l'amour
les lumières doivent réhaussé l'ambiance
romantique dans la peinture dans la
peinture qui colore la tour eiffel
il y à un pigment jaune la lumière jaune
fait ressortir ce pigment c'est ça la
source principale du succès de cette
opération la proche de l'éclairage est
complètement différent puisque les
lumières de nuit doivent traduire les
sentiments voir l'expression du monument
l'éclairage de la tour eiffel et c'est
de valoriser larchitecture de cette
attraction parisienne la nuit la tour
eiffel c'est l'étoile de paris
[Musique]
ceux qui travaillent dans la tour en
sont très fiers quelques-uns même trop
fier on dirait qu'ils l'ont bâti
il ya un sentiment de possession parmi
les gens qui travaillent ici en
particulier ceux qui accueillent les
visiteurs
[Musique]
mon travail c'est d'organiser des
visites
je suis responsable des groupes on se
trouve maintenant dans le pilier nord il
existe à un pilier dans chaque coin de
la tour ou des ascenseurs sont installés
là-bas c'est le restaurant de la belle
france est au dessus c'est le restaurant
parisien
ce sont les deux restaurant du premier
étage là bas on voit la galerie multi
salle de cinéma où l'on peut trouver une
poste des magasins de souvenirs des
buffets des marchands de glace il y a
beaucoup de choses intéressantes dans la
galerie initialement le tour était conçu
pour représenter un monument
incontournable pour les touristes
et aujourd'hui elle ne cesse pas de
l'être cependant ces vues magnifiques et
sa hauteur stupéfiante sont parfois la
scène d'accident regrettable il y a des
gens qui essayent de sauter de la tour
en moyenne 380 personnes se sont suicidé
pendant une période de trois ou quatre
ans on cherche à contrôler la situation
on essaie de les raisonner
on cherche à comprendre les motifs on en
parle avec eux le plus longtemps
possible avant que les gardes n'arrive
dès lors c'est la responsabilité des
pompiers les tours vous offre le plus
souvent la possibilité de vous retrouver
en présence de gens à la recherche de
rencontres sympathiques ou même
romantique
j'ai vu beaucoup de couples se
promenaient se tenant par la main
ils y viennent pour célébrer un
événement ou un anniversaire le travail
exige aussi qu'on les déconseille
d'écrire sur la tour
la plupart du temps on les chasse on
cherche à les attraper parfois c'est un
jeu entre les touristes et les employés
on est sur le troisième étage de la tour
près du restaurant jules verne
situé au sommet du 3ème étage le
restaurant est un des symboles de paris
c'est le meilleur endroit du monde à
moins qu'un restaurant existe au sommet
du mont everest
depuis longtemps les cérémonies les
fêtes gastronomiques son traditionnel à
la tour eiffel pour les français mangent
et ne signifie pas se nourrir pour eux
la cuisine est une passion ça faisait à
peu près cinq mois que j'étais arrivé à
paris
j'ai dit à ma femme que j'avais une
maîtresse elle m'a fixé du regard et je
lui ai dit c'est une affaire qui dure
depuis des années
elle semble plus étonné cinq minutes
plus tard je lui ai dit que ma maîtresse
était la tour eiffel il ya des artistes
qui dessine
il y a ceux qui travaillent la pierre
le grand chef alain rex préfère
pratiquer sa magie culinaire au
restaurant huppé
le jules verne quatre étoiles qui se
trouve au milieu de la tour et j'avoue
que la vue de paris m'inspire elle
m'inspire de créer de nouveaux plats
chaque jour on à 115 employés dans le
restaurant jules verne seulement il y a
beaucoup de bruit beaucoup de gens
j'aime ça c'est un peu lusine il y à
beaucoup de monde
j'aime beaucoup ça armé de spatules deux
batteurs deux couteaux de moule à
soufflé le grand maître rex et son
équipe lutte pour l'honneur de la france
la spécialité d'aujourd'hui c'est une
salade de homard en sauce corail
c'est du homard français la tour eiffel
a été conçu pour inspirer de nouvelles
visions aux gens elle encourage aussi
l'imagination des artistes au restaurant
le jules verne
ces deux forces se mêlent c'est un
mélange appétissant qui ne pourrait se
produire que dans la ville de lumière
[Musique]
on appelle souvent paris la ville de
lumière mais de quel genre de lumière
s'agit-il
[Musique]
s'agit-il de la lumière sur la culture
française ou bien de la lumière du ciel
éclairant les monuments et berçant les
amoureux dans une brume coloré de rose
[Musique]
on
peut-être que ce sont les lumières d'un
cabaret ou toulouse-lautrec peigné est
joué
[Musique]
à moins que ce soit l'éclat d'un manège
qui reflète les yeux des jeunes amoureux
toutes ces images représentent la
lumière de paris cependant c'est dans
l'allégresse silencieuse de la tour
eiffel qu'elle trouve sa voie la plus
vibrante
je crois que la tour eiffel possède une
place unique dans le monde
elle s'est presque transformé en mythe
pourquoi je ne sais pas c'est peut-être
parce que c'est une façon de glorifier
la science on l'a construite à une
époque où l'on croyait que la science et
la technologie rendre l homme heureux à
mon avis elle est très spécial à cause
de sa forme et très facile à dessiner
je pense que c'est un objet inutile et
comme tous les objets inutiles d'une
valeur thérapeutique
la tour eiffel reste un monument
irrésistible symbole de la puissance
française
la tour eiffel
et tout simplement un hymne à l'amour et
à la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]